in our series a more perfect union we
need to show that what unites us as
Americans is far greater than what
divides us this morning CBS Evening News
anchor Jeff Glor brings us the story of
a principal who goes above and beyond to
bring his students together by meeting
some of their most basic needs oh my
sweet lord Akbar cook calls it the big
room whatever you guys need we have the
place where he stores hundreds of
donated bottles of laundry detergent
fabric softener and dryer sheets inside
Westside high in Newark New Jersey we've
been getting a lot of community service
you know help from all around the states
the big room was a solution to a big
problem my kids weren't coming to school
some of kooks kids he calls them all his
babies weren't showing up because they
were wearing dirty clothes and getting
bullied I think we really put the
microscope on basic needs of kids like
we everyone wants to high test scores
everyone wants them to perform well but
if the kid don't feel confidence and
just coming to school and being that
person that we know they can be then
what are we doing before you raise the
SAT scores how about giving somebody
some clean clothes and you go fight for
that baby the way you want them to fight
on that test
the famous washes in dryer today
Westside has 5 commercial grade washers
and driers
Deshawn Denny and Brianna singleton used
them all the time when you first got it
all right well I was kind of scared to
bring my clothes over but I just I
struggled it off so when I went to cook
I asked them
Killick I use the UH the rod rematch he
like no you good we know about family
and here you could bring it any time you
want
principal cook who grew up in Newark
also started a program called lights on
he opens his school from 6:00 to 11:00
p.m. on Fridays during the school year
and three nights a week during the
summer 6 p.m. to 11 p.m. you're supposed
to be home eating dinner doing homework
leasing that's not the case my babies
are taking care of the younger siblings
that parents are either working hard and
just kind of tickle these odd jobs or
the parents are not there at all
the kids use the gym dance and are fed
more meals it is a long way from what
Westside was just a few years ago in
this line of work I have to go
undefeated because if I lose I could
lose a lot a kid's life so you have to
just keep this pounding the pavement
like I'm not this genius my babies came
with a school and I have to help them
navigate it even though we students eat
Cheetos more like with his child like we
could come in with a bad day we taught
Sohn he may God a better that's pretty
cool it might seem hard to believe that
one person could clean up a school and a
whole neighborhood but in Newark the
proof is in the principle this is
selfless work that we do no one goes
into education thinking they're going to
get rich not getting a medal at the end
of the day no sir but I have a gold
medal around my heart from the love that
the kids could get back to me and just
that the families and the communities
that are are taking it one step further
so I can't you give me goosebumps tell
he's rooting for every kid what inspired
the principal cook to get into education
he has educators in the family both of
his hands were teachers but he did he
drifted a bit in in college and after
until he found his calling but now that
he has it is 24/7 phone I mean this is
you see that anything but a nine-to-five
job he's there at night he's there on
weekends he is thinking about the kids
constantly the pack must be huge I mean
you know when you when you when you get
help a kid like well that's the thing he
says I didn't go to this to get rich you
know I go into it to be rewarded by by
helping these kids and seeing how they
succeed down the road let's just say
this how many people have a gold medal
around their heart and feel that Akbar
cook does oh for sure all these students
his babies yes I like that little gray
patch too he's got a 20 year old son he
calls us baby stop very cool
what a great story Jeff thank you good
to see you guys